you know we have to stop meeting like
this i'm used to
the old school where you meet face to
face i mean what's going on here
i know i know it's the new weird world
but
you know uh it's temporary and then we
will find our way back we'll
there we go there we go and um how are
you happy valentine's day week
thank you very much happy valentine's
day week and i and i must tell you drew
i know
so much about you from behind the scenes
of my daughter
nicole you two are the the bandits from
behind that i always get to hear what
you all are doing from time to time so
just know that i've
i've grown up with you and then i've
grown up with you if i could say that
correctly
it's true i love your daughter so much
and i know she's sweetheart
recently her and our group of
girlfriends really helped each other on
we were like we just have to do this we
just have to do the zoom thing
it's not what anybody wants to do but we
can't
we have to maintain our connection
because you just start to
feel like life is a surreal memory well
what i love about it is that when you
all finish
those talks it's almost like you're
saving the world i just want to know
what your conclusions are at the end of
all this
because i can you cover every subject
you guys are just amazing
it's an amazing group of women but your
daughter is the
biggest asset and you have so much to do
you know with that she's such an
incredible woman
i'm in fact i spoke with her on the show
she i believe was in the same
area but with her uh bearded dragon
speedy
yeah yes i have a bearded dragon too
and the reason i have a bearded dragon
is because my daughter
olive got one and guess what her latest
pet was is
i'm i'm so afraid tell me snake
and she brought it home and it's so
dainty and cute i was like oh this is
gonna be great
and then she's like and it's gonna grow
to six feet and i was like oh
no no what what what kind of snake drew
it's a corn snake
what are you kidding me
i know it's like we have a zoo in our
house that's a complete menagerie
i i'm still trying to get over she
brought this bearded thing out
and and she kept saying dad pet it
i'm thinking never are you what what
happened
what happened to a dog what happened to
a cat what
the simple things of life oh you know
what i don't know what to say about the
two of you i i just
just uh you know what every time i go
down that rabbit hole of nicole i always
go oh
i don't want to know i don't need to
know you just don't need to know
we're boring and tame now you'll be glad
to know we're
good girls moms you know
and your journey in
songwriting there's just so many
chart-topping epic
songs but the stories behind them
would you mind telling us some of them
and we can peel back the curtain and
play something we're calling
on the records with lionel richie
sure i lo i'd love that i love it
let's do it okay here's how it's going
to work we're going to name a song
uh you wrote and then you could tell us
the back story our little unknown fact
that might surprise us
okay good good good okay lady
wow okay lady was called
baby baby
right i take it to the commodores the
commodores say we don't want
a ballot this time okay i get a call
from
kenny rogers saying i want one of those
kind of songs
that you do uh i fly out to vegas
he tells me about oh my god my marriage
i'm
i'm so in love this and i've never met a
lady before like the lady i have
how could a guy like me have such a
great lady
by the way lionel what's the name of the
song i said
lady
so baby ladies same thing it's such a
beautiful word too
lady you know absolutely very good
how about the song hello ah
my co-producer uh james carmichael was
actually coming to the house and i was
just doodling at the piano
and he walked in and i played these
cards and said hello
is it me you're looking for and he said
finish that song
and i said no no no no i was just
kidding hello as a media looking forward
it's got to be the corniest thing i've
ever said in my whole life
and and and he said no no no no finish
the song and of course i i from there
finish the song and the rest is
history history oh my gosh okay what
about
we are the world um it was one of those
things where
um i'm at michael's house now the
obstacle of writing the song was not
writing the song
the obstacle of writing the song was he
had the
the albino python that he lost
in the bedroom um and so we're writing
the lyrics
and all of a sudden the albums fall over
on this because he put his albums
against the wall
and i'm lying on the floor and i hear
these were this little sound
and i look over my shoulder and there's
this
albino python head looking at me
uh drew i was screaming like the last
horror movie that you've ever seen in
your whole life
i mean and he kept saying to me lionel
he loves you he just wants to say he
loves you
so sort of make a long story short right
after that
we put the snake away i'm a nervous
wreck and then we write the lyrics to we
are the world i mean that's
that's the tidbit behind the tidbit
because writing the song was just
glorious but
but that was the thing that was
happening while we were writing the song
and that's the stuff we live to know
about
and thank you so much for sharing it
you